[Musique]
salut les amis
je suis vraiment ravi de parler devant
vous ce soir je suis un petit peu peur
pour être très franc de faire ce talk je
voulais pas le dire au début mais je
pense que c'est plus honnête de le faire
parce qu'on va aborder un sujet qui est
extrêmement tocci qui m'aime moi dans
les activités peut me retomber un peu
dessus je risque pas de dire deux choses
complètement folles mais ça reste des
risques comprend et c'est le cas pour
vous en faites aussi à chaque fois que
vous parlez à chaque fois que vous
prenez la parole
que ce soit avec vos amis avec vos
professeurs en entreprise et ça vous
prenez un risque en donnant vos opinions
et c'est justement ça qu'on devrait
combattre en fait ça ne devrait plus
être un risque il ya évidemment des
choses qui ne tiennent pas de l'opinion
et je veux balayer tout ça mais tout ce
qui tient de l'opinion de la vie ça ne
devrait pas être un risque on devrait se
sentir justement en totale confiance se
sentir écoutés sortir contredit et aimer
ça
moi j'ai 24 ans je suis je suis plutôt
jeunes en fait quand j'ai pas
l'impression parfois mais je suis plus
tout jeune et j'ai l'impression que ça
part en couilles en fait non mais
vraiment que depuis la crise de 2008 qui
a été catastrophique
au final on a appris à voter contre
quand on a appris à voter utile et
aujourd'hui on voit juste plus du tout
et c'est super dangereux en fait et même
moi le premier j'ai pas envie de voter
j'ai pas de candidat qui me plaît je
pense que c'est le cas de beaucoup
d'entre nous
et c'est un vrai problème parce que si
on y regarde de plus près au delà des
considérations parfois un peu trop
facile de des gens se sont battus pour
le droit de vote sont aussi battu pour
qu'on s'abstienne c'est surtout que
c'est important en fait on est en train
d'élire les gens qui ont le pouvoir du
public donc ça n'est pas tout la société
mais en france spécialement c'est une
partie est extrêmement importante de
cette société et donc j'aimerais que
ensemble on se dise comment un autre
niveau individuel et puis collectivement
on peut réussir à créer une société de
lait coûte une société plus saine une
société où en fait on construit plutôt
que passer notre temps à essayer de se
rassembler en petits groupes en bulles
comme ça a été dit tout à l'heure qui
vont constamment s'auto-entretenir pour
au final avec des vers toujours plus de
radicalité et ça peu importe les bords
politiques si vous croyez que y'a que le
borda adverse qui est trop extrême dites
vous que le bord adverse trop extrême
vous considère vous comme trop extrêmes
prenez conscience de ça essayez
d'écouter votre empathie et par empathie
dans le sens de vouloir aller dans le
sens des idées de notre personne
empathie vraiment dans la compréhension
sincère presque naïve
j'aimerais que d'abord on crée une
culture dans ce pays de désaccords
profonds et pas une culture des accords
seulement sur les plateaux télé qui
aujourd'hui je pense qu'on mette
d'accord ne représente plus du tout la
population déjà parce qu'ils habitent
tous à paris parce que sinon ils
seraient pas vraiment sur les plateaux
télé en fait
aidé et aussi parce que
voir des plus de 35 40 ans en
costard-cravate
suffit de se balader un petit peu en
france pour voir ce n'est pas ce à quoi
fait donc du coup j'aimerais pour
recréer cette culture de désaccord dans
mon média on a fait un débat entre deux
mondes totalement opposés on a fait
plein drame a fait un spécialement entre
deux mondes totalement opposées entre
bruno qui est policier et qui est plutôt
défenseur de la police en expliquant que
c'est elle qui est victime de tellement
d'injustices et de l'autre chine qui est
un jeune de quartier qui est devenu
journaliste indépendant grâce à ses
vidéos qui ont fait le buzz des lots
sociaux dans les trois l'ont vu des
dizaines sont même que savoir que ça
venait de lui
quand on a commencé le débat quand on a
commencé avant le débat à introduire
cette séquence shine été avec plusieurs
amis c'est nous qui nous avait pas
prévenus donc ça nous a un peu inquiété
parce que comme nous a pas prévenus on
ne savait pas si jamais je connaissais
pas chaline on avait échangé au
téléphone il avait l'air très sympa mais
je ne savais pas si jamais sa portée un
risque bruno était lui tout seul et
quand j'ai dit à bruno en ayant un peu
d' avance dans le couloir que yahvé à
shine venait avec trois personnes et a
touché son peu son pistolet en disant
non il y aura pas de problème
bruno sait on sait quoi la définition ne
veut pas de problème parce que là je ne
suis pas certain de la hourva et donc du
coup ça commençait le débat ça a été
extrêmement tendue et vous retrouverez
ça sur youtube vous verrez mais moi je
suis tout blanc comme
je suis en train de me dire j'ai même
demandé à plusieurs personnes de
l'équipe de descendre alors qu'il
n'était pas nécessaire sur le plateau
justement pour faire nombre montré que
le bas parce qu'on pense qu'on aurait
fait d'ailleurs mais montrer qu'on peut
faire acte de présence quoi
et puis au détour de quelques blagues
certaines des biens une certaine de
shine certaines de bruno ou détour d'une
discussion de plus en plus apaisée et
qui essayait vraiment d'aller dans le
sens de l'autre
et sont rendus compte qu'en fait ils
avaient des choses à se dire
il n'était pas d'accord et ne sont
toujours pas aujourd'hui mais il avait
des choses à se dire il avait besoin
réellement de crespo fondamentale
détruits depuis trop longtemps
entraîné par les réseaux sociaux
récupéré par les politiques
[Musique]
et via mon les médias qui sont profite
pour faire des mais on devine sur les
réseaux sociaux à la télé
entre nos débats on fait toujours un
débrief qui permet en fait de montrer au
public aux gens qui nous regardent qu'en
fait ce n'est pas une mise en scène mais
que tout ça est aussi un un acte
délibéré de débats d'idées que ce n'est
pas une embrouille réel fondamentale
entre êtres humains il faut réhumaniser
un peu nos idées parce que je vous le
dis vous en rendez pas compte mais à
l'assemblée nationale où sont les
plateaux télé il sur le dessus mais ils
sont très bas dans polisse est pour
beaucoup d'entre eux
est dense débrief là on les a vus ce
marais on les a vus faire des
concessions sur les positions des uns et
des autres et on les a vus surtout se
rendent compte que il n'avait pas envie
de se détester il n'avait pas envie pour
la mentalement de s'opposer il défend
des des intérêts différents et la
politique ça ne sera toujours que ça je
passe vous pensez que je fais indice
prendra effet en disant qu'on va tous
ces mets et faire des champs et se tenir
avec la main comme ça bien sûr que non
évidemment que non
mais on peut faire ça dans un cadre
correct un cadre civilisé un cadre
bienveillant au final ces intérêts
divergents serait délibéré
démocratiquement on y lirait les gens en
fonction de leurs idées en fonction des
intérêts qu'on détendre en fonction des
intérêts qu'on croit que eux
représentent pour nous
et on aurait dans cette culture du
désaccord une réelle envie de voter
parce qu'on voudrait battre nos
adversaires ne voudrais pas tuer nos
ennemis aujourd'hui
j'ai vraiment peur qu'on s'en approche
mais ce n'est pas le seul problème
le problème aussi c'est que la société
du privé mrc des américains pour ça va
tellement plus vite que la société du
public et je suis entrepreneur donc je
peux vous le dire j'ai une entreprise
privée profitable
ça va tellement plus vite que le privé
en une semaine on peut réussir fait
tellement de choses que dans le public
il aurait fallu dix contre-pouvoirs et
je dis pas qu'ils sont pas nécessaires
je ne les connais pas assez mais
aujourd'hui ce décalage est beaucoup
trop gros ça veut dire fondamentalement
et rendez vous composez vous-même la
question vous même
en fait vos séries préférées
votre instagram de tik tok vos
applications comme hubert ou autres sont
en concurrence avec de la politique avec
des programmes avec des articles de loi
avec des amendements c'est aucune chance
de gagner
enfin je dise ils ont prévu les
visiteurs sur tf1 vous voyez bien
l'histoire en fait c'est que les gens
préfèrent regarder les visiteurs plutôt
que le débrief d'une élection
présidentielle en tout cas en terme
d'audience c'est le pari tf1 fait et ça
c'est parce que notre politique qui est
ringarde et c'est pour ça je vous ai dit
que j'ai peur de faire ce talk c'est que
je le pense peut-être ça va tirer des
problèmes mais je suis obligé de le dire
c'est la vérité et on le ressent tous
ici
on a monté une application qui permet
justement de vulgariser les programmes
ont pensé ça marcherait bien on avait
une idée que ceux y avait quelque chose
qui se passe est que nous quand on avait
la bêta sous les yeux on tenait quelque
chose qui nous nous parlait et ça n'a
pas manqué comme ce tome sera publiée on
sera trois millions de téléchargements
en l'espace de deux mois et demi et
battu tous antico vide qui est une
application obligatoire sur les stores
et pourquoi pas ce que vous lisez vous
voulez tout ce dépliant papier des
candidats
j'ai un média politique et société
peut-être que je devrais pas le dire
mais moi non plus je lis pas on trouve
les informations à différents endroits
il ya quelques excellents médias de
notre génération que je vais pas citer
pourquoi qu'est de concurrence entre eux
mais vous les connaissez qui font ce
travail là extrêmement bien
mais aucun outil fondamentalement adapté
à nos usages et c'est ça le sujet
aujourd'hui on peut pas on va pas être
en concurrence dans notre temps de
cerveau disponible parce que c'est la
donnée la plus importante de notre
époque on peut pas être en concurrence
avec des choses aussi bien foutu que du
game of thrones que du tic toc ça n'a
pas de sens de croire ça ça serait naïf
en fait et donc du coup on peut croire
que la politique devrait être à
l'ancienne qu'on ne rigole pas avec ça
que c'est des choses trop sérieuses et
constater de l'abstention augmenté
jamais s'arrêter atteindre des sommets
vertigineux jusqu'à même qu'on va parler
dit légitimité démocratique
on peut embraser l'époque et se dire
qu'il ya pas que des choses horribles
dans cette époque et c'est à nous
d'adapter ces choses très sérieuses
parce que évidemment elles le sont mais
adapter ces choses très sérieuses à nos
usages et à nos réalités qui se sont
totalement fait bouleversé par tout ce
qu'on vit
mais si on avait résolu ça tout ne
serait pas finie il ya un autre sujet
également
c'est le sujet des gens qui nous
gouvernent
je pense que lee gilet jaune était le
bon exemple de ça et avec plus de 2
euros le litre d'essence n'est pas à
l'abri que d'autres choses reprennent
dans ce genre là
ya autre chose il ya la contestation de
nos élites politiques et c'est pas
seulement le gouvernement c'est plus
globale c'est d'innombrables histoires
qui nous ont fait douter
d'innombrables
coups fait par les uns et les autres
mensonges trahisons
malhonnêteté discours ce dieu dont les
yeux on s'en rappelle encore ils ces
choses là elles nous ont fait douter et
nous on fait assimiler un pattern
dangereux mais néanmoins ultra ancré en
nous qui l élitisme des politiques qui
en fait nous empêche et empêcherait
quelqu'un
du peuple d'en bas comme on disait tout
à l'heure qui aurait mis six générations
a émergé d'émerger réellement et donc sa
question la légitimité
comment majorité de français qui sont
justement ces gens là qui vont gagner le
smic un peu plus comment ces gens là
peuvent se sentir c'est le mot
représentés par des gens qui ont fait
sciences po l'ena plus grande école je
dis pas que c'était dit académique n'est
pas extrêmement talentueuse et
compétente mais là on parle de
représentativité pourquoi jean lassalle
nous fait sourire à chaque fois qu'il
prend la parole
parce qu'on sent que c'est la france on
sent que c'est une partie de la france
on sent qu'il va porter des
revendications qui réellement concerne
les français et pour qu'on en a pas plus
de gens comme ça parce que peut-être que
c'est les gens là sont moins technique
ils connaîtront - le droit européen il
connaît trop - l'exacte taux d'inflation
de cette année là ils seront moins à
l'aise peut-être devant une caméra pour
voir le discours parfait et lisse mais
on s'en fout en fait on a envie de se
sentir représentés on a envie quand on
regarde sa famille quand on regarde ses
proches quand on regarde ses amis on a
envie d'avoir l'impression ça pour être
eux nos politiques en fait
comme nous et qui a pas de raison que ça
soit pas nous qui dirigeons dans un
autre démocratie représentative en plus
ce qui se passe dans le pays et cette
crise d'illégitimité est d'autant plus
dangereuse
que plus les choses avancent plus elle
paraît de plus en plus cerné dans un
moule unique
et que ça ça risque de poser des
problèmes aussi en termes de lutte des
classes parce que c'est aussi ça le
sujet c'est que si jamais il n'y a
jamais autre chose qu'une forme
d'élitisme nous nous sommes deux
bourgeoises et qui atteint les sphères
du sommet du pouvoir il y aura jamais
ces retours profond de gens qui ont
connu des situations
qu'on doit connaître si on veut être
capable de gouverner un pays de plus de
65 millions d'habitants
est qu à crise d'illégitimité serait
terrible parce qu'elle ne se règlerait
que dans des protestations infinie
vendant des choses encore plus violente
et c'est ça qu'on doit changer la
question ça ne paraît distant ont dit ok
d'accord on fait quoi du coup table rase
et on change tout non on peut pas ça
marcherait pas comme ça et en plus on
prendrait le risque de reproduire
exactement le même système juste en
ayant eu un an ou deux ans on a juste
renverser la table
non ce qu'il faut c'est prendre le
pouvoir chacun d'entre nous il ya déjà
la question du privé aujourd'hui le
privé et les associations offrent un bon
exemple mais il y en ad'autres nous avec
notre entreprise et beaucoup d'autres
mènent des combats public avec des
entreprises privées car ils se sentent
dépossédés de leurs moyens c'est une
vraie piste et personne peut l'occulter
mais j'aimerais que ça revienne déjà
centré sur le citoyen de la question de
confiance en fait c'est cette confiance
qui créera la prospérité dont on a
besoin et cette question de confiance
c'est repartir aux fondamentaux de d'une
acceptation de la différence d'opinion
et de comprendre que quelqu'un peut
voter de philippe poutou à eric zemmour
était légitime dans son rôle de citoyen
français
et que l'erreur
ne serait pas de ne pas le combattre
pas vouloir le comprendre parce que
c'est à l'ombre de notre compréhension
que les plus grands dangers politiques
naîtront et si vous souhaitez combattre
ou l'un ou l'autre c'est en comprenant
pourquoi ces gens là vous vous retrouvez
à s'identifier à ces personnes et à
vouloir défendre leurs idées que vous
comprendrez réellement le pays dans
lequel on vit et vous pourrez agir
globalement dans votre quotidien la
politique le sens premier du terme c'est
la vie de la cité tout n'est pas
dépendant de décisions de l'état vous
n'est pas dépendant de décision de
député ou de sénateur c'est aussi à nous
c'est à nous de prendre le contrôle de
ce qu'on fait et ça va juste de la
gestion de bistrot du restaurant et du
bar du coin qu'on menace de fermer où on
met une pression sur le loyer
jusqu'aux décisions européennes
françaises voire mondiale comme sur des
questions de guerre
on a le pouvoir individuellement et et
c'est là que ça m'intéresse le plus
collectivement les réseaux sociaux nous
ont donné quand même une arme incroyable
c'est la capacité de nous réunir nous
mobiliser
utilisons utilisons là pour la mobiliser
sur les causes qui nous tiennent à coeur
et faisons pression sur ses causes qui
nous tient à coeur parce que là ça sera
beaucoup plus facile de faire plier les
décisionnaires et même s'il ne plie pas
ça montre à une puissance tellement
forte que ça peut faire permettre de
faire décider de manière citoyenne de
désobéir à ce que large partie du peuple
refuse d'accepter
s'il vous plaît ne tombez pas dans cette
incompréhension dans ce rejet de l'autre
pour ses idées politiques c'est
tellement contre-productif c'est
tellement éloigné du football nous
puissions faire tout cette ouverture
ultra nécessaire ça veut pas dire que
vous défendrez les mêmes intérêts ça
veut pas dire que ce sont vos amis ça
veut juste dire que c'est en ayant cette
bienveillance qu'on recrée le cadre
démocratique dont on a tous besoin
et chacun d'entre nous pouvons être le
fossoyeur la goutte d'eau qui fait
déborder le vase mais à linverse chacun
d'entre nous nous pouvons être cette
graine qui va permettre à un arbre
magnifique que se développer et nous
abriter et dort d'assainir notre
démocratie merci de l'avoir écouté
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]